hey i'm spider-man i'm spider-man i'm
spider-man
this is so cool we should do this again
you got it
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and we have really
really exciting news today in case you
have not heard spider-man no way home is
coming back to the theaters yes it has
been out on digital but for those who
love the movie theater experience you
can once again experience spider-man no
way home in the theaters but the cool
part is is this isn't going to be the
same experience because apparently they
are adding at least five new scenes to
this version that is going to be playing
back in theaters this version that is
going to be playing in theaters is
apparently called the spider-man no way
home the more fun stuff edition and
according to sony we can see this new
version of spider-man knowing home in
movie theaters on september 2nd of this
year and like i said we know at least
five scenes that are actually going to
be added to this movie so let's talk
about them and of course if you love
marvel and spider-man be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel and spider-man news
so thanks to admit shidhari a graphic
designer and visual effects artist in
the industry we know at least five
scenes that are going to be added and
what they are about and i'm really
really excited for some of these scenes
according to amit's tweet sony pictures
is saving these and more to cross the
two billion dollar mark in theaters for
spider-man no way home and emit listed
the run times as well we have the first
deleted scene which is an interrogation
scene extended this apparently is going
to be 2 minutes and 25 seconds the
second deleted scene is peter day at
midtown high which is going to be 5
minutes and 25 seconds the next one is
going to be undercroft montage which is
going to be 1 minute and 35 seconds then
we have another deleted scene that is
happy's very good lawyer which is one
minute and 35 seconds as well and you
know this is about daredevil and then
the one that i am most excited for which
is a deleted scene titled the spidey's
hang out which is going to be four
minutes and 25 seconds now all of these
sound like they are going to be really
really fun scenes i am most particularly
excited about the scene that is the
spidey's hangout i really really want to
see all of the footage that they have of
andrew garfield toby maguire and tom
holland just kind of hanging out when
they meet each other i feel like we're
gonna get some pretty funny scenes but
also some pretty touching scenes as well
the whole science bros scene in the
laboratory with the three peters trying
to create a cure for all of the villains
is an amazing scene it's awesome to
watch the three of them work together
but also work individually on each
individual villain as well and one of
the best things that i loved about
spider-man no way home is watching the
chemistry between each of the actors
that play spider-man we have three
generations of spider-man here and they
interact with each other in a very very
amazing way and this scene is four
minutes and 25 seconds long plus they
said they are going to be adding more
scenes as well so who knows what we're
going to be getting in this we could get
more laboratory time we could get some
more web action time more fighting time
we could even get more time when the
spider-man originally meet i would love
to see an extended little fight between
andrew garfield spider-man and toby
maguire's and if they want to pull out
my heartstrings just a little bit more
when toby and andrew first see tom
holland's peter parker after me just
died well i'm totally down for that as
well and of course like i mentioned
there's a scene titled happy's very good
lawyer which we all know is matt murdock
aka daredevil now this scene is going to
be a minute and 35 seconds but since we
only got about a minute of matt murdock
in the actual film i'm totally down for
another minute and 35 seconds of matt
murdock now i don't think that they're
going to mention daredevil but i do
think they'll hint at it obviously like
they did in the movie where he caught
the brick and said he's a very good
lawyer plus not to mention we do have
the daredevil disney plus show coming
within the next few years hopefully so
giving us a little bit more of what to
expect from charlie cox's matt murdock
again is going to be really cool and he
did amazing in this movie and he did
amazing of course as daredevil himself
in the whole series and overall
spider-man knowing home was just one of
those once in a lifetime experiences
where you just go to the theater with
all of this excitement built up excited
to watch the movie ready to watch the
movie popcorn in hand i think it's just
going to be amazing to get back in the
theaters and do that again so let me
know how excited you all are in the
comments down below also sadly i think
this is only in the u.s and canada for
now but i'd be really surprised if they
didn't eventually do this for all of the
other countries in the world and of
course if i hear anything i'll be sure
to update everybody so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you